I just don't think anyone should be able
to make decisions about anyone else's
body it doesn't it doesn't really make
any sense to me I think there's a level
of obviously What's Happening Here in
the country at the moment is
I don't really know where that ends like
you know at that point is it
you know someone needs an operation and
someone can decide that they can't have
it and
um it just it makes no sense to me I
think we live in a world where we feel
like we're always making the right steps
and there's a lot of people who are
taking
positive steps and I think it's it's
quite scary to see kind of like just how
far backwards we're going in a lot of
ways